the concentrator of lightspeed has a
profound implication for both space and
time
implications that we would know
intuitively if we routinely travel near
the speed of light or routinely saw
objects that zip by us near the speed of
light but since we don't generally have
those experiences let me show you what
you would see if you did encounter an
object that was traveling near the speed
of light and let's do a little example
we'll slow it down so you can see it
with a taxicab traveling near the speed
of light and what you would find is that
the length of the taxicab along the
direction of motion is compressed it's
shrunken it's called Lorentz contraction
and directly comes from Einsteins
mathematics in special relativity all
along on the speed of light being
constant now as it turns out if you
really did encounter a taxicab going by
near the speed of light that your eyes
had the ability to see you wouldn't
actually see what I've shown you here
you see something a little bit different
because you see if you think about it
what you see at a given moment comes
from the light entering your eyes at
that moment now when you are considering
an object different locations on that
object are different distances from your
eyes which means that the light you see
at a given moment left the object at
different moments the farther away a
point on the object is the longer the
light travel time said the earlier the
light had to leave for you to see it at
a given moment
and when you take that mouthful of
complexity into account it has an impact
on what you would see in fact it would
look something like this so here's a
taxicab rushing by you would have the
compression the contraction along the
direction of motion that I described a
moment ago but you'd also see an
interesting kind of twisting of the
object coming from the
complexity of the light travel time now
this is what you would see on the
sidewalk you might think from that
picture that a person in the taxicab
themselves would be feeling kind of
cramped claustrophobic as the taxicab is
kind of crushing it around them but
that's not right if you jump into the
taxicab
then from your perspective it's the rest
of the world that's rushing by the
taxicab seems normal ordinary but when
you look out at the world all of the
strange wondrous distortions apply to
the streets and the buildings everything
around you so this is the impact of
motion on space we see this kind of
dramatic twisting warping transformation
of the environment all coming from
either your motion through it or the
motion of an object through the
environment that you're observing a
profound impact on space from motion
you